ah parents when you're growing up you
can't help but look up to them
literally they're taller than you are
but is this metaphorical stature
warranted
sure they want what's best for you but
did you know that they were probably
willing to lie to you to get it that's
right
your parents lied to you about the law
the thing is
if your parents didn't go to law school
for three years and especially if they
don't have a popular law related youtube
channel
can you really trust them the answer is
no
and legal eagle is here to replace them
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
when it comes to our parents and the law
the real question is did our parents get
anything right and why did all of our
parents tell us that you have to turn
off the dome light in the car while
you're driving well we're gonna find out
today
so let's talk about the things that your
parents told you about the law that are
probably not true
the first of course is staying home
alone while your parents shopped kevin
mcallister was home alone for several
days and he totally handled it so
why is it that our parents told us that
you couldn't stay home alone i know more
than a few of you fantasized about
ordering a pizza and jumping up and down
on your bed while your siblings were
forced to spend time at some old
relative's house and of course we all
planned to do
this i'm gonna give you to the count of
ten to get your
ugly yellow no good keister off my
property
before i pump your guts full of lead but
of course our parents were worried that
we were going to do this
johnny i got so much energy we better
start doing stupid
so i suppose this might explain why
after the success of home alone and its
numerous sequels
why our parents didn't trust us to
outwit hapless burglars on our own and
of course they claimed that it was
illegal to leave you at home even if
they were just running to the store
but is it in fact true that the state
makes it illegal to leave your kids
at home without supervision or were your
parents just lying to you out of
convenience well the verdict
guess what they probably lied to you
there isn't a universal age that is
considered appropriate for leaving
children home alone only a few
jurisdictions even have firm rules for
how old the child must be before they
can stay at home
unsupervised for example maryland makes
it illegal to leave a child under 8
years old home alone and a babysitter
for someone under 8 must be at least
13 years old and believe me maryland is
not messing around even when it's not
technically against the law just ask the
couple who let their quote free-range
kids
aged 10 and 16 play unattended in a park
only to have child protective services
called on them for neglect the parents
eventually won but not before their kids
were interviewed for
hours by the local government and after
years of litigation the local maryland
government worse than harry and marv
we know that you're in there and that
you're
all alone i will let you decide on that
one and illinois sets the bar
even higher it's considered abuse or
neglect to leave a minor under the age
of 14 home quote
without supervision for an unreasonable
period of time without regard for the
mental or physical health safety or
welfare of that minor but of course
there is some wiggle room here what is
considered an unreasonable period of
time that implies that there is a
reasonable period of time that you can
leave a child unattended and it's not
unreasonable to leave a child at home if
the child would essentially be safe but
most states leave it to their local
department of health to create
guidelines in these local authorities
consider many different factors
they consider the child's age maturity
level how long the child's guardians are
gone whether the house and neighborhood
are safe
whether the child can easily contact
their parents or other adult and most
importantly
whether the child can defend themselves
from two violent criminals using nothing
but toys leftover fishing equipment
and a tarantula you guys give up or
you're thirsty for more
so there you have it your parents lied
to you zero to one which takes us to the
one that
i don't know every single child was told
when they were growing up that
you cannot have the interior lights on
in the car while it's driving
at night now there's nothing more
nerve-wracking for a parent than
watching their immature 15 year old
climb into the driver's seat of a
killing machine you know
your car what you thought would happen
when you learned to drive and what your
parents thought would happen the minute
you got your license
and of course it was no picnic for your
own parents when they're driving in the
pitch blackout
and their snot-nosed kid i.e you want to
turn on the interior light so you can
get into even more shenanigans in the
back seat so of course
our parents all told us that whether you
were driving or whether they were
driving
it was of course illegal to drive with
your interior lights on
but was it the verdict your parents
probably lied
but they probably did so for the right
reason almost everyone watching this
video remembers their parents teaching
them that they could get a ticket if
they drove with the overhead or mirror
lights on
but think back to your actual driving
test did they ask you a single question
about
leaving the interior lights on while you
drove no
they didn't that's because spoiler it's
not
illegal whether it's advisable to drive
with the interior lights on is a
completely separate question with a
different answer but the answer is that
it's
really not a good idea the light might
produce glare
on the windshield that makes it harder
to see if the interior is really bright
it makes it almost impossible to see
stuff
on the outside that's really dark a
light is also just another distraction
especially if the light is on so that
you or the passenger can look at your
phones
or a map or anything else that pulls
your attention away from the road but
think about it the automotive industry
is one of the most regulated industries
in the country it has been for forever
do you think that if it was illegal to
turn the dome light on in your car
that cars would even allow you to turn
that light on while it was moving
there's a million things that don't work
in the car when you're actually moving
they have the technology to turn it off
but of course that's separate from the
idea of whether you should actually do
it or not and as phil defranco likes to
say don't be stupid
stupid so parents zero you two your
parents keep lying to you but let's talk
about
skipping school because this is one
thing that all parents want their kids
to actually do and as eagle-eyed
observer daniel rodier said it was
hammered into me that it was
against the law for me to not be at
school of course the perfectly valid
reason you have for skipping school
compared to what your parents think
happen
when you skip school the verdict well
this one could go either way but i lean
on the side of this being
more false than true now before your
parents can protest let me explain
although the law typically says that
more than three unexcused absences makes
a child truant which is against the law
it's not strictly illegal for students
to miss school at all times
for example in california a school will
report students as truant if they miss
school three times without a valid
reason
or permission but what counts as a valid
reason to miss school
the exceptions include but are not
limited to religious holidays family
vacations medical appointments
illnesses suspensions family emergencies
if you're the victim of bullying
or for a much-needed mental health break
related to because you needed to sleep
in the weather is nice the weather is
bad the weather is sad
it's the end of the world as we know it
it's opening day backstreet is back
you're a senior a cute girl wants you to
a cute boy wants you to the mcrib is
back the movie theater is playing all
three lord of the rings movies in one
day your future's so bright you gotta
wear shades
there's a new legal eagle video it's
tuesday your animal crossing turnip farm
needs attention
or you watch the lost finale okay some
of these may not
technically qualify as exceptions but
the law is a fluid thing it's only not
the case until
someone takes it to trial and makes some
case law about it but some of these are
in fact ironclad excuses for not going
to school
so be sure you're taking notes this one
your parents 0 u3 though this might have
an asterisk this one
sort of depends on the circumstances for
which you are not going to school but
that takes us to the next thing that our
parents said
was illegal it was that you can't drive
without wearing shoes or you can't drive
wearing flip-flops i'm talking to you
florida
here of course is what you think you
look like driving barefoot compared to
what your parents think will happen when
you drive barefoot so
the question can you legally drive
without wearing shoes your parents
thought
the answer was clear absolutely not and
of course driver's ed
instructors also reinforced the idea
that you have to wear shoes to drive
potentially just because they didn't
want to smell
your stinky feet but people have
wondered whether it was illegal for
decades to get to the bottom of this
researcher jason r heinberg did a
research project in the early 90s on
whether any state actually made it
illegal to drive barefoot he contacted
every department of motor vehicle office
in the united states
and it turns out that none of the 50
states or the district of columbia
barred shoeless driving alabama does
have a law requiring you to wear shoes
while operating a motorcycle
if you're driving a motorcycle wear some
shoes and also a helmet and a leather
jacket but
even alabama doesn't say anything about
wearing shoes in a car
but before you celebrate by burning your
shoes and running to your car
there's one important loophole to think
about the illinois director of driving
licensing and school safety
told heimberg that even without a
specific law on footwear police could
still give a citation
illinois statues 21-901a and b prohibit
reckless and negligent driving the
director said quote
a driver charged under these articles or
any article would have a right to trial
where the barefoot aspect of the case
might be disputed and so the verdict
there's no specific law that seems to
make driving without your shoes on
illegal it's entirely possible that some
other motor vehicle law
applies and doing so would be either
reckless or negligent so your parents
might have actually told the truth for
once even though they didn't actually
know it and my verdict might surprise
you but
i think the police have a lot of laws
that they can use to give you a ticket
just like the grand puba of the illinois
driving safety said so the bottom line
if you get in an accident while driving
barefoot
you might expect to be charged with
negligence reckless driving or operating
a vehicle in an unsafe manner so check
your local ordinances before defying
your parents on this one and as for
flip-flops
alright so that does appear to be legal
but podiatrists hate them because they
destroy your feet
safe driving experts also hate
flip-flops because they tend to get
caught in the gas or brake pedals and of
course
anyone that cares anything about fashion
hates them because flip-flops
are terribly ugly but your parents
arguably get one back
your parents didn't lie to you on this
one parents won you three
but that takes us to one last car
related issue because
again apparently all kids cared about
back in the day was being able to drive
a ride in a car and that's of course
our parents told you that riding in the
back of an open pickup truck was
illegal you and your parents envisioned
riding in a truck bed exactly the same
way you just had a different opinion of
how it would turn out so the question is
is it against the law to ride in the
back of a truck and the verdict is in
and it depends jurisdictions vary a lot
on whether you can legally ride in the
back
of a truck in many states it's not
against the law for anyone to roll down
the street in the back of a truck bed
other states ban
riding in truck beds except under very
certain circumstances
ohio law is pretty representative of the
states that have restrictions
state law bans people 15 and under from
riding in the back unless the vehicle is
driven less than 25 miles per hour or
the person is seated and belted in an
oem seating position of course many many
states now have adopted seat belt laws
that
mandate that everyone in a moving
vehicle actually wear their seat belts
and the truck bed is not
a likely place to find a seat belt so if
you can't wear a seat belt then you
can't ride in the back of a truck but if
your parents didn't want you riding in
the back of a truck they probably had
really good reason the national highway
safety transportation board
says that trucks are three times more
likely to be involved in a rollover
crash
and a rollover crash is responsible for
the highest number of fatalities and if
you're not
seat belted in to the back of a truck
your odds are not
very good if you get into an actual
crash so be sure to check with your
friendly neighborhood personal injury
lawyer
before you decide to stand up in the bed
of a truck so i'm gonna give this one to
your parents
a solid not lie your parents to you
three and finally let's talk about one
that we all heard growing up that you
cannot put a penny on the railroad
tracks
because it might derail a train as a kid
you instinctively knew how fun train
tracks were
of course your parents were worried this
would happen and apparently the people
of reddit have been told many times that
it's against the law to put a penny on
the railroad tracks
because it might derail the train really
mom and dad i mean let's see what
actually happens when you put a coin on
the railroad tracks here youtuber
millennium force demonstrates exactly
what would happen when you put the coin
on the track you mean the tiny coin
wasn't able to derail a train that had
hundreds of thousands of tons of cargo
being transported your parents lied to
you well
they definitely lied about the
derailment part but that still doesn't
answer the question
is putting a coin on the railroad track
illegal and the verdict is
yes it is illegal to put coins or
anything else on the railroad track
most states penalize people if they mess
with train tracks even if it's not
actually going to cause a derailment for
instance texas penal code section 28.07
makes it a crime to interfere with
railroad property this crime includes
situations where a person quote places
an obstruction on a railroad track or
right-of-way california's law makes it
clear that any obstruction is a crime
quote every person who maliciously does
either of the following is punishable by
imprisonment places any obstruction upon
the rails or tracks of any railroad or
of any switch branch branchway or
turnout connected with
any railroad the any obstruction could
even include
a coin now a smart lawyer could devise
perhaps a decent defense because
as the video demonstrates a flat penny
is not exactly obstructing anything but
that's
probably not the argument you want to
have to make in court in addition most
states make it illegal to cross train
tracks at any other place than a
railroad crossing a typical state
criminal trespass law looks like this
one from kentucky
it shall be unlawful for any person
without the consent of the railroad to
go upon the track property or
right-of-way of a railroad other than to
pass over the track property or
right-of-way at a public or private
crossing therefore
hanging out by the train tracks to test
the penny theory is
probably technically trespassing so that
seems to even things out your parents
three
you three and now we go on to the
lightning round where we talk about ding
dong ditching the act of going to
someone's doorbell ringing it and then
running away when i asked this question
in the community section someone said
their parents warned them that it was
illegal to play a game called rattitat
ginger and according to wikipedia this
is
an american variant of a game known as
alternatively
knock down ginger ding dong ditch chap
door run
chappies knock knock zoom zoom belfast
knick-knack and numerous other variants
now i promise i am
not making any of those up these are
various things for what we americans
call
ding-dong ditching but the essence of
the ding-dong door ditch is ringing a
doorbell and then running away before
someone answers it and these days
your parents and you probably have the
same general idea about why someone
would do this or why you shouldn't be
doing this yeah
youtube stunts don't always turn out the
way that we think they do
but could this actually constitute
illegal trespassing
the verdict well your parents probably
spoke the truth it probably is illegal
to play the game known as ding dong door
ditching or any of the
ridiculous uk variants of that name
because you're probably trespassing on
private property here's how it breaks
down when the property has a sign that
says no trespassing you can't knock on
the door for
any reason but if you ring the doorbell
or knock when the house doesn't have a
sign
this is probably legal if you're there
for a legitimate reason like
selling candy bars so you can go to band
camp or whatever camp you wanted to go
to but if you're just there to disturb
the homeowner and then run or hide away
well the property owner could
potentially call the cops and
unfortunately there are lots of stories
of angry homeowners doing really bad
things to
children who ring the doorbell and then
run away not that those people are
justified you can see my entire video on
the case of the shotgun booby trap
that's highly
illegal but your parents are probably
more concerned about you being safe
than being arrested for trespass so okay
fine maybe your parents didn't lie
about absolutely everything but you
still can't trust them especially
because i explained a whole bunch more
honorable mentions of
things that you out there in the
community provided of things that your
parents said which were
clearly not illegal and clearly were
said only for their own convenience
because i put an extended version of
this video on nebula
if i talked on the hour drive home they
could legally do a citizen's arrest
in fact almost all of my videos have an
ad-free extended version that comes out
early on nebula and now you can get a
huge discount
bundled with curiosity stream because
sometimes talking about things that your
parents said were
illegal that actually weren't illegal is
a little too hot for youtube which is
why me and my creator friends teamed up
to build our own platform where creators
don't need to worry about demonetization
or the dreaded algorithm it's called
nebula and we're thrilled to be
partnering with curiositystream
because nebula is a place where creators
can do what they do best create it's a
place where we can
both house our content ad free and also
experiment with original content and new
series that probably wouldn't work
on youtube and nebula features lots of
youtube's top creators like
extra credits real engineering thomas
frank and also
half as interesting is there and we also
get to collaborate in ways that probably
wouldn't work
on youtube like alex goes bananas where
i explained to a teenager all the crazy
things that happened in the 90s
that he can't possibly comprehend
because his tiny teenage brain
is far too tiny so what does this have
to do with curiosity stream well as the
go-to source for the best documentaries
on the internet
like peter sagel's history they love
educational creators and we worked out a
deal where if you sign up for curiosity
stream with the link in the description
you also get nebula for free and to be
clear that nebulous subscription is not
a trial it's free for as long as you're
a curiosity stream member and only for
the next couple of days curiosity stream
is offering
41 off of their annual plans that's less
than 12
a year for both curiosity stream and
nebula together and after that you'll
still get 26
off which is still a smoking hot deal
for both curiosity stream and nebula so
if you click on the link in the
description you'll get both curiosity
stream and nebula
for 41 off or you can go to
curiositystream.com
legaleagle it's a great way to support
this channel and educational content
directly for
now less than 12 a year for both
curiosity stream and
nebula so just click on the link in the
description plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel so do you
agree with my analysis of the legal
things that your parents said were
illegal
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other videos about crazy
laws and legal misunderstandings so
click on this playlist and i'll see you
in court